allez on va passer à cette information
merci Myriam en tout cas qui est tombé
dans l'après-midi l'écrivain réalisateur
à succès Frédéric bebédé a été placé en
garde à vue àau suite à une plainte
déposée durant l'été par une jeune fille
pour viol il a finalement été relâché en
fin d'après-midi on va vous expliquer
euh toute cette affaire dans un instant
euh avec notamment Michel Marie et avant
de de expliquer l'affaire on aura aussi
Bruno de stabenrat et Jean-Christophe
florentin qui sont des amis qui vont
revenir sur la personnalité de
l'écrivain et euh voilà ce qui s'est
passé on va le savoir puis qu'on a des
infos exclusives en plus qui nous ont
été donnés sur cette affaire petit récap
merci
mirriam l'information est tombée en
début d'après-midi l'écrivain Frédéric
becbéé placé en garde à vue après une
plainte déposée cet été par une jeune
femme Frédéric becbédé a donc été placée
en garde à vue ce matin à poau pour être
entendu dans le cadre d'une enquête pour
viol pour rappel il y a quelques mois
l'homme avait créé la polémique lors de
la promotion de son dernier ouvrage et
avait été accusé par certaines de faire
l'apologie du
viol selon la jeune femme qui a porté
plein contre lui et qui aurait entretenu
une relation pendant plusieurs mois avec
le romancier l'effet se serait déroulé
dans une chambre d'hôtel la garde à vue
de l'écrivain qui ni l'effit a été levé
en fin d'après-midi alors bbéd a été
placé en garde à vue pour viol que
s'est-il
passé ma Brou la coiffure Michel dis-moi
il est devenu ple celui-là il est devenu
Playboy il est devenu Playboy on le VO
les émissions total maintenant il est
devenu play cel
c'est quoi cette pou de folie on dirait
borsalino on diritire de
la j'adore Michel très beau bravo Michel
merci pas mal aussi notre délire un peu
anglaisy c'est vous qui l'avez coiffé ou
quoi non mais sans déconner on dir verd
lundi comment ça va oh c'est gentil ça
ça va jeanchristopime bien comme ça un
peu don des idées su j'aime bien le dé
bon on va on va parler de de tout ça
dans dans un instant merci en tout cas
d'être là vous êtes content d'être là
c'est normal je vous ai invité Bruno est
avec nous un pote ça va mon Bruno salut
sir ça vaès bien s'est pas vu nous bah
oui j'adore Bruno Bruno c'est un mec
exceptionnel vous connaissez l'histoire
Bruno bien sûr on peut raconte-nous ton
histoire Bruno bah qu'est-ce tu veux que
je raconteous par Me tellement de Ch non
lui c'est un mec exceptionnel il un film
sur toi c'est sa je suis je t'adore tu
sais ouais mais merci touche beaucoup
c'est vrai ouais vraiment vraiment et
c'est quoi son hisire ben non non j'ai
eu un accient de voiture il y a une
vingtaine d'années et puis j'ai raconté
mon histoire et l'histoire l'a permis de
d'ouvrir des débats Bruno c'était un
kiffeur en fait c'est vrai Bruno B ave
touour kiff avec Frédéric voilà et il a
eu un accident de voiture et et voilà et
c'est vrai qu'il était toujours un
kiffur d'ailleurs et j'adore ce et puis
il y a 2 ans quand je suis venu ouais
c'était pour l'ami guness ou exactement
ouais
par un ami de il a fait unequête un
livre absolument incroyableouis et qu'on
cherche partout alors aviez Duon
toujours parce que le Parisien l'avait
trouvé ouais ouais non
mais dans 7 a eu un Tho C il y a eu un
Théo qui travaillit chez toi qui m'a
appelé ouais bien sûr tu sais qu'il
avait vu vivant dans un TG je dire envo
envoie-moi la envoie-moi la photo mais
le type avait rien à voirou rien il
avait 50 ans Xavier il a 60 ans le mec
faisait tu vois 50 kg is Xavier Xavier
du P is c'est vrai que c'était une
histoire de fou c'est vrai que cétait et
je pense que c'est pas fini c'est vrai
quoi tu penses quoi moi je pense qu'il
est vivant ah ouais je pense qu'il est
aux États-Unis je pense que voilà c'est
fou tu penses qu'il est aux États-Unis
oui vraiment oui as des pistes ou bien
tu penses non mais il y a eu il y a eu
un témoignage assez assez troublant
d'une famille qu'il connaissait très
bien mais qui parlera jamais
ouais c'est fou tu penses qu'il s'en est
s s'en est sorti c'est incroyable c'est
c'est fou cette histoire on va on va
revenir sur Frédéric bebéd et on va dire
ce qui s'est passé dans dans un instant
c'est vrai que toi bon tu c'est c'est
c'est un pote à toi
c'est à toi vous êtes amis depuis
environ 40 ans c'est ça oui comment tu
décrirais Frédéric parce que là il est
sorti de garde à vue est-ce que tu as
des news déjà est-ce que bah tu sais que
Frédéric il a un avantage c'est que il
est il est écrivain et donc depuis 40
ans il raconte sa vie dans les livres
donc on connaît ses addictions on
connaît ses divorces on connaît son
rapport qu'il a eu avec la cocaïne avec
l'alcool avec ses exfemmes il est assez
clair comme garçon et donc l'histoire de
viol évidemment tant que l'enquête sera
pas mais moi je pense qu'il est qu'il
était pris au piège comme je pense
beaucoup de de de comédiens d'écrivains
d'acteurs d'animateurs qui sur les
réseaux sociaux se font piéger
maintenant on envoie des photos on
commence une conversation et puis euh et
puis parfois on tombe dans le piège
alors on va voir ce que dit la la
justice he bien entendu sur cette
affaire parce qu'on peut pas se
prononcer et dire c'est un tel raison un
tel à tort on va voir lesffit dans un
instant avec avec Michel Marie mais toi
ton je voulais avoir ton sentiment
d'avant et Jean-Christophe vous aussi
vous vous vous le connaissez bien je le
connais très bien ou on a même fondé
notre première société notre premier
journal ensemble en 92 donc ça fait 31
ans si je calcule bien bientôt 32 donc
oui ça fait un petit moment je me
souviens quand tu entendu était garde à
vue aujourd'hui tu t'es dit quoi je
tombé de ma chaise ouais encore un ben
ça y est encore un plus voilà on a eu le
covid il y a quelques années là on a la
la violite aigu non puis il y a un
problème sur les générations
d'aujourd'hui comme tu disais filles de
17 18 20 22 ans c'est plus c'est plus
les mêmes que notre génération à nous
c'est des filles qui vont sur les
réseaux sociaux qui sont assez
provoquantes garçon fill d'illeurs PZ
pas quand même dire ça il y a quand même
des des vrais
Vic on a l'impression qu'il y a que des
femmes qui disent
nimporte moi je connais très très bien
Frédéri par ailleurs aussi mais voilà il
faut quand même dire qu'il y a pas que
des fantasmes très bien que tu le dis
bien sûr alors justement vous faisiez
partie d'un d'un club qui s'appelait le
cacass club décrit comant lie de fête
avec les plus belles filles pour
raconter ces soirées ouou bah c'était
c'était un club qui a démarré chez
Castel dans les années 80 et et qui
existe toujours c'est qu'on a toujours
un site où on on se voit et donc on se
connaît bien on s'est il y en a qui sont
mariés qui on eu des enfants et donc
voilà mais pour revenir à
Frédéric un viol c'est quand même une
histoire sérieuse tu vois c'est 10 15
ans de prison donc c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut pas prendre la légère moi ce
que je voulais simplement dire c'est que
euh quelqu'un que je connais depuis
longtemps je je connais son rapport aux
femmes qui peuvent être conflictuel mais
qui n'est absolument pas un rapport de
de comment dire de de brutalité ou de
violence je pense qu'il s moi je le
connais par cœur donc je pense qu'il
s'est fait piégé entre entre guillemets
mais vous êtes dans un bar vous prenez
un verre c'était à PO c'est une viille
c'est ma ville natale donc la connaît
très bien la fille est rentré avec lui
alors ce qui est étonnant c'est qu'ils
ont fait l'amour alors justement on va
parler de l'histoire dans un instant
vous allez voir mais
Jean-Christophe y a Frédéric qui dit
dans un de ces livres qu'il prend de la
drogue pour calmer ses frénésies
sexuelles euh oui mais il en a fait un
bon moi j'ai jamais connu frénétique
comme ça comme il le décrit mais enfin
en tout cas ça fait des beaux bouquins
après puisqu'il a eu le pris
interalliier avec une après une première
garde à vue mais donc peut-être que ça
va nous donner un prochain chefduvre
comme tu disais comme tu disais tu
disais ouais il dit tout parce que dans
ses livres voilà il a parlé il raconte
tout il est il est sans filtre Frédéric
et donc de voilà donc qu'il est avis
entendu parler de cette histoire ou pas
toi parce que tu l' je sa que la PL
était fa en juillet c'est ça donc le 23
juillet il il le savait ou pas
euh il l' su après ouais il l'a su après
et bah évidemment il est tombé des nuus
mais surtout il y a cette histoire enfin
que je trouve à Ben rent de viol digital
ça c'est la première fois que j'entends
ça c'est un viol hein oui je sais je
sais
mais on va on va parler on va en parler
dans un instant de de tout ça c'est vrai
que mais juste moi je voulais avoir
juste comme vous êtes ses potes quand
vous avez quand tu as entendu
aujourd'hui qui était en garde à vue tu
as essayé de l'appel tu t'es dit quoi
écoute non non moi j'attends le
j'attends de de l'avoir au téléphone et
puis surtout j'attends s un peu le
retour de la justice quoi c'est-à-dire
d'avoir les les rapports de les rapports
de police c'est ça alors on a des on a
voir ce que dit la fille en fait mais il
faut écouter bien sûr qu'il faut écouter
les victimes sûr bien sûr alors on va
revenir euh sur l'affaire avec bien sûr
Michel Marie qui va nous raconter ce qui
s'est passé et c'est vrai que Gill aussi
je sais que tu as des infos qui sont
tombées puisqu'on a eu des infos de de
la garde à vue de comment s'est passé la
la gardeevue de de de de Frédéric becbéé
juste il il dit c'est vrai qu'on sait
que Frédéric il aime bien le monde de la
nuit de la fête voilà il c'est c'est
voilà dans les soirées c'était c'était
quoi cétait c'était la folie ou pas non
mais enfin c'est un enfin comme nous
tous enfin quand on a eu 20 ans on a
fait beaucoup la fête bon lui il a
continué un peu son adolescence et euh
bon il a il a dit qu'il avait terminé
avec l'alcool avec la drogue il vit au
Pays-Basque maintenant donc donc il est
puis il est père de famille il est bien
marié donc il est dans une autre étape
de sa vie alors de temps en temps oui
moi je l'ai vu il y a pas longtemps pour
la signature de son dernier livre B
habit du champagne mais ça resté très
très sage quoi et puis surtout je pense
qu' il sait aussi ce qui se passe dans
dans notre monde d'aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il faut faire attention quand vous
êtes quelqu'un de connu vous êtes
quelqu'un de
vulnérable et si vous êtes un peu
fragile alors c'est c'est c'est pas pour
comment dire vous êtes pas connu vous
pouvez être aussi oui non bien sûr non
mais là je pasle dans le filtre B BD
quoi moi je connais bien Frédéric ça
enfin je le connais depuis 30 ans aussi
ça a été mon éditeur pour trois livres
quand il était éditeur chez flamarion
donc j'ai eu la chance de travailler
avec lui c'est un éditeur absolument
brillant et visionnaire quelqu'un de
vraiment de de très talentueux après
j'ai connu aussi les soirées chez Castel
où oui effectivement c'était bah une
autre époque ouais rock roll voilà une
une époque un peu déjantée il est très
festif très gay très joyeux moi voilà
avec moi il a toujours été absolument
exemplaire et et très talentueux mais
voilà non moi ce que je vous reprochais
un petit peu c'est en fait
d'essentialiser c'est-à-dire que il y a
l'affaire de be béd là qui est une
affaire mais il y a pas aujourd'hui une
sorte de grand complot français avec des
filles qui vont aller traquer des mecs
connus pour les faire tomber pour viol
il y a aussi beaucoup de victimes de
viol et d'agression sexuel on en parle
tout le temps et donc voilà il faut pas
non plus les invisibiliser sous prétexte
que aujourd'hui il y a des hommes connus
qui sont sont en avant tous les soirs à
la télé bien sûr on peut pas l'exclure
non plus pardon on ne peut pas l'exclure
non plus de
systémati qu'il veut le là le bég
là Michel on va revenir donc sur sur
cette affaire racontez-nous alors ce qui
s'est passé avec les nouveaux éléments
qu'on a avec gin alors le 23 juillet là
de cette année une jeune fille de 17 ans
va au commissariat de police déposer
plainte commissariat de peau déposer
plainte pour viol et elle cite son
agresseur comme étant Frédéric
becbédé le parquet ouvre une enquête
préliminaire et ce mardi
[Musique]
le becbd était convoqué au commissariat
de police il est placé en garde àue ce
qui est la rgle entre guillemets la
règle du jeu là où ça se complique un
peu c'est que la victime est une de ces
relation c'est-à-dire qu'il avait une
relation habituelle avec cette jeune
fille je sais pas ça durait pas depuis
des années puisquelle a 17 ans on peut
discuter du fait qu'elle est 17 ans mais
elle est
majeure pas enfinelle la majorité
sexuelle après on ne juge pas la morale
en
France on y viendra peut-être un jour
mais en tout cas pour l'instante pas
encore la morale donc cette jeune fille
et sa petite amie entre guillemets enfin
une de ses enfin sa
maîtresse ils ont passé la nuit ensemble
dans un hôtel à peau ils ont eu une
relation intime à un moment donné dans
cette chambre d'hôtel et elle était
consentante en revanche il a
voulu réitérer
son l'acte et du coup elle était plus
consentante et elle prétend elle affirme
qu'il qu'il l'a violé de de façon
digitale bon
euh c'est c'est quand même une ambiance
un peu compliquée un peu
complexe évidemment si elle ne voulait
pas avoir cette deuxième relation
sexuelle c'est tout à fait son droit et
si il l'a forcé effectivement il y a
viol mais là je souhaite bon courage aux
enquêteurs aux magistrat instructeurs
pour démêler le vrai du faux parce que
lui conteste farouchement les faits donc
là dans ces cas-là c'est comme souvent
la parole de l'un contre la parole de
l'autre et on va croire qui contre
cramer non mais on croit qui on croit on
croit BBD on croit cette jeune fille
c'est extrêmement compliqué il y a pas
de il y a pas de comment dirais-je de de
de preuve scientifique d'ADN de choses
comme ça ils sont ensemble dans même
chambre d'hôtel effectivement il y a
sûrement de l'ADN partout des deux donc
en terme de pocechn itifique il y a rien
en terme de téléphonie il y a rien donc
c'est
pas c'était revu entre cet été et
maintenant ou pas du tout al ça je n'ai
pas cette information je me rappelle il
étaprès G on sait pas on sait pas non
non on sait pas il en garde à vue depuis
depuis depuis ce matin donc alors la
garde à vue a été élevée ce qui est
plutôt bon signe c'est que les policiers
lui ont posé les questions qu'il
considérait devoir lui poser et ils
l'ont remis en liberté à ma connaissance
il n'est pas mise en examen donc il a
pas été déféré devant un juge
d'instruction ce qui ne veut pas dire
que l'enquête s'arrête à ce stade elle
va certainement se poursuivre il y a des
investigation à mener elles vont être
menées mais aujourd'hui Frédéric bebéé
ni totalement les faits et cette jeune
femme affirme cette jeune fille affirme
que qu'il a eu viol voilà peut-être
juste une une précision on en parle
parfois mais c'est pas parce qu'il y a
eu un rapport sexuel consenti je je je
démant pas ce que vous avez dit mais je
voudrais va appuyer il peut très bien y
avoir un premier rapport sexuel consenti
et un deuxième forcé et c'est ça reste
un viol ça peut être un viol
rappectateur qui nous rejoignent c'est
ça c'est qu' c'est l'absence de
consentement rappelez parce qu'il y a eu
un premier oui il y a eu un un premier
rapport sexuel consenti là tout le monde
est d'accord il peut non non mais je je
déms pas je je dis j'ai dit exactement
la même chose je dis mais là je suis
complètement d'accord avec vous sauf que
la difficulté la difficulté
ONM bien sûr non mais c'est pour aussi
c'est pour aussi les téléspectateurs ça
c'est pas parce qu'il y a un premier
rapport c'est pas parce qu'on fait
l'amour une première fois qu'une
deuxième fois on peut se passer de
consentement et je rappelle que même
dans un couple l'absence de consentement
c'est un viol he voilà viol conjugal et
on parlait de pénétration digitale c'est
aussi un viol hein toute forme de
pénétration est un viol ce qui dit alors
c'est ce qui voilà ce sera une
pénétration digitale qui est un viol ça
il faut le dire aussi alors c'est vrai
qu'il ni et son avocat a même demandé en
garde à vue des actes d'enquête
complémentaires alors ça c'est un peu
pour retourner la situation mais il a
tout à fait le droit c'està-dire qu'il
va demander je pense il y a-t-il des
expertises médicales parce que c'est
peut-être le point faible est-ce qu'il
peut y avoir une confrontation est-ce
que le dossier peut avancer comme ça
pour le moment il est pas mis en examen
mais l'enquête préliminaire se poursuit
donc sur le déroulé des faits et sur la
manière dont ça se terminera pour le
moment on ne peut absolument rien dire
voilà le témoignage le témoignage et la
plainte de cette jeune femme ont paru
suffisamment crédiible pour que une
enquête soit ouverte alors jeis donc ce
serait déroulé dans une chambre d'hôtel
comm la garde à vue été levée en fin
d'après-midi Absolum alors juste pour
dire l'hôtel dans lequel ça se serait
passé et bien connu de Frédéric
beckbudet puisque c'est un hôtel dont je
crois il a été lui-même actionnaire
pendant plusieurs années exactement la
ville la Navar donc il a été actionnaire
je crois de 2011 à 2015 voilà donc il
connaît l'endroit ce qui ne préjuge de
rien égal voilà la garde à vue bah voilà
il s'est exprimé et encore une fois pour
que son avocat demande des actes
complémentaires c'est une manière de
entre guillemets selon la défense de
Frédéric bebedé potentiellement frag
fragiliser le témoignage de la
plaignante en disant nous allons
contre-attaqué voilà j'ajoute quand même
que le fait que la garde à vue a été
levée que il n'est pas été ni mis en
examen ni comme témoin
assister laisse entendre quand même la
fragilité de l'accusation oui vous
rajouter quelque chose et
l'impossibilité d'établir des preuves
donc c'est Paro cont par on verra ça on
verra dit ouais ça être compliqué et
franchement j'ai toujours connu Frédéric
entouré j'ai jamais de problème de de
pour séduire ou pour avoir les les plus
belles filles du monde à ses pieds ou
c'est une rockst donc c'est une rockstar
franchement donc est-ce qu'il a besoin
de c'était sa peti
am pas besoin de forcer quoi ça fait
toujours penser au voisin qui a tué 40
personnes dans l' immeuble et quand tu
interview les gens ah bah il était super
gentil du en a jamais eu d'histoire avec
lui ça fait toujours penser à ces
histoires là ça c'est bizarre c'est à
chaque fois qu'il y a des histoires
comme ça il y a des gens qui viennent
oui mais vous inquiétez pas tout va bien
non mais ça veut dire qu'on connaî
jamais les gens on connaî jamais les
gens dire tu l'as dit tu t'as dit ce que
je voula dire on peut pas connaître les
gens à 100 % peut-être 99 c'est mon
ressenti he après oui c'est le ressenti
de des j'étais pas ni sous le lit j'ai
pas mis de caméra audessus je sais pas
je sais bien sais bien voilà non mais
c'est c'est oui non mais en fait moi je
pensais aussi je me la fille elle est
jeune mais 1 donc elle est parents 17
ans elle est mineure ouis c'est pas la
fille qui alors à ce momentl si vous
parlez des par
ma pourquoi tu vas chercher une
17s age c'est pas la
question questionamour avec une petite
de 17
ans il a 58 ans il veut faire l'amour
avec une petite de 17 ans et ben c'est
qu'il a de bases des problèmes
psychologiques je suis désolé mais ça je
vous dis pas le contraire on juge pas la
mor on peut le dire quand même parce que
is il une rel depis plusieurs Mo é on n
pas relation quand on
a vous êtes pas juge
de moralité il fait ce qu'il veut la
vraie question c'est est-ce qu'il y a eu
viol ou pas viol après qui qui dorment
avec une jeune fille qui couche avec une
fille de
1ille elle est peut-être aussi très JEE
savoir ce qu'elle a vraiment envie de
faire 17 ans c'est très jeune mais je
dis pas le
contraire donc SS veulent pas se mettre
aussi dans la merde ben qu'ils arrêtent
de s'intéresser à des gamine voilà
désolé la morale elle a pas t c'est la
morale là c'est là là vous parlez de
moral et on peut comprendre peut
comprendre ce que vous dites après la
loi là on parle on parle au point de vue
la loi et il il y a rien de de
répréhensible si à part voilà part s'il
y a eu bien sûr non consentement lors du
deè rapport c'est ça qui problme
l'urence mais mais sinon ça c'est de
l'ordre de la morale Kelly voilà c'est
c'est 58 ans 17 ans on peut on peut rien
dire voilà ce qui va après on disent s
font ce qu'ils veulent si c'est une
histoire d'amour qu'ils ont envie de
vivre bon après c'est vrai que c'est
voilà c'est il y a un gros écart mais
bon les investigations qu'il vont qui
vont être mené maintenant c'est essayer
de savoir s'il y a eu un différent entre
eux qui juste justifierait qu'elle ait
déposer cette plainte oui parce que
c'est ça qui pose question qui donne
plutôt je trouve du poids à la parole de
la victime c'est quel intérêt elle a à à
à porter plainte comme ça pour viol
c'est on sait très bien qu' une femme
qui porte plainte c'est un un tas d'EM
merde qui commenceelle a redouter
affronter la parole des policiers
gognard et cetera même si ça s'est
amélioré la parole des la famille
qu'est-ce qu'il faisais avec lui et
cetera c'est beaucoup d'emmerde dont on
pourrait se passer aisément donc si elle
le fait c'est quand même qu'elle a une
bonne raison qu'elle pourrait être cette
raison bon en C ça donne du poids à son
témoignage enfin son mais je oui Bono tu
voulais dire non non je disais en fait
en t'écoutant je pensais aussi aux
parents quand tu as une fille de 17 ans
c'est une fille qui est relativement
jeune et et elle en a sûrement parlé à
ses parents enfin tu vois ça ça compte
aussi c'est c'est pas une fille de 25
ans quoi c'est exactement ouais c'est
vraiment une ouais bref quoi c'est ça
c'est une fille de 17 ans c'est vrai que
c'est c'est à prendre en compte c'est
vrai que 17 ans c'est c'est extrêmement
jeune elle a pas forcément dit à ses
parents chez la maîtresse de Frédéric
bebéd non mais maintenant il alors
justement il il est marié toujours oui
une vie de famille oui ah d'accord oui
oui c'est que des c'est que des mecs
mariés he ah ou ou bah toutes les
histoires qui sortent c'est que des mecs
qui on a pas de célibataire dans les
histoires là il ils tombent tous un par
un à chaque tous les soirs on parle d'un
gars ça tombe comme des mches regardez
bien un mec qui arrive j'ai pas de meuf
il ont tous me et c'est pas fini nous
dit c'est pas finiah non ah ouais non je
pense pas toi tu sais tout surt to tu
tu c'est vrai ven avec
un en fait faut pas être ton copain quoi
merci à vous en tout cas d'avoir été
avec nous je ne sais pas du tout ce
qu'il y a ce soir sur C8 mais c'est être
un régal merci à
tous
merci